hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israel ich
habe mir gedacht ich mache noch ein
kleines rezept zum muttertag ich
verschenke zum muttertag ganz gerne
blumen aber keine echten blumen
ich finde es immer ziemlich schade wenn
die abgeschnitten werden deswegen mache
ich heute erst mal blumen und zwar habe
ich hier cake pops gemacht als rose
das heißt meine mama krieg dann eben zum
muttertag rosen geschenkt im innern habe
ich ganz normal im cache den können die
auch geschmacklich gestalten wie ihr
möchtet und außen herum habe ich die
deko mit moderner schokolade gemacht das
ist auch richtig schön schmeckt auch
wirklich hervorragend und ich starte
jetzt direkt und zeigt euch mich die
cpus hergestellt habe für die cake pops
werde ich jetzt einen weg zu bereiten
dafür brauche ich 150 gramm zerlassene
butter 150 gramm zucker etwas extra
prise salz drei viertel teelöffel
backpulver zweier 200 gramm mehl und
etwas milch
ich mache es einen all in teig das heißt
alle zutaten kommen in die rührschüssel
zusammen
denn da geht es jetzt nicht darum dass
ich viel luft in der teig ein schlag
sondern dass der teig schnell gebacken
wird weil er später sowieso zerkrümelt
wird
jetzt gibt es erstmal nur ein bisschen
milch getreide und falls ihr merkt der
teig ist zu fest und einfach etwas mehr
dazu
jetzt will ich den teig in die
vorbereitete backform ich habe den wagen
auf etwa 30 cm eingestellt aber ihr
könnt den teig zum beispiel auch in dem
backblech backen
jetzt wird der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 140 grad ober unterhitze
für etwa 15 minuten gebacken
natürlich kann die backzeit variieren je
nachdem was eine backform ihr habt wenig
stets grobe mit dem zahnstocher macht
oder teig durch ist könnte ein frohes
nehmen
der teig gebacken und ich habe ihr noch
abkühlen lassen und in der zwischenzeit
habe ich auch schon eine gallas
vorbereitet das heißt ich habe sahne
aufkochen lassen habe weiße schokolade
eingerührt und solange gerührt bis sie
sich aufgelöst hat
jetzt ist das ganze etwa lauwarm und
jetzt nämlich den kuchenteig und muss
inter bröselt das mache ich jetzt in
einer großen schüssel
geschmacklich könnte die cake pops
selbst gestalten wie ihr möchtet die
weiße schokoladen ganache ist ja
ziemlich geschmacksneutral
ich gebe jetzt noch etwas zitronenschale
abtrieb mit rein dann schmeckt nämlich
frisch und fruchtig sollte natürlich
eine unbehandelte zitrone sein
jetzt gebe ich noch kokosraspeln mit
dazu ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel
anderen dichter nehmen die ihr vorher
klein gemahlen habt also alles ist dann
noch für den fruchtigen geschmack etwas
himbeermarmelade und jetzt gebe ich nur
soviel kann schmidt dazu so dass eine
klebrige masse entsteht also lieber erst
mal weniger jetzt alles gut verrühren
und gleich verkneten wir es auch mit den
händen
von der konsistenz sollte die cache
masse jetzt so sein dass wenn ich sie
zusammen drücke dass sie schön zusammen
bleibt falls jetzt mal zuviel kanals
oder flüssigkeit mit dazu gegeben habt
könnt ihr auch immer mal zum beispiel
text rösel mit rein geben und ich stelle
die masse jetzt für fünf minuten den
kühlschrank und dann geht's gleich
weiter
jetzt kann ich die kickbox formen und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier einen torten
retter bereits mit backpapier belegt und
nehme jetzt einen ice portionierer dann
werden nämlich die kugeln alle gleich
groß stellte ich mir das so einen ab und
zwar sitzt der kleinste 1 portion ihre
den ich hab da hat glaube ich
zweieinhalb zentimeter durchmesser zwei
oder drei jetzt freue mich erst mal eine
kugel und da muss man manchmal einfach
nur bisher durchkneten damit wieder fest
wird 210 cool im kühlschrank kurz und
aus dieser kugelform ich jetzt so einen
tropfen also einen kegel
da ist jetzt auch ganz wichtig damit wir
später eine richtig tolle rose
hinbekommen
da kann ich den hier abstellen
die knospen kommen jetzt für fünf bis
zehn minuten in den kühlschrank der
weisen sie ein bisschen fest und in der
zwischenzeit wenn ich ein klein wenig
weiße kuvertüre schmelzen
jetzt wo sich die catwalks sticks noch
an den knospen befestigen und zwar
traurig dafür die cape sticks in die
quartiere einst so etwa einen zentimeter
tief und dann wird es direkt in den
cache pop eingetaucht ist etwa bis zur
mitte und jetzt könnt ihr die entweder
liegend lagern also hier
oder was ich besser findet damit sie
keine druckstellen bekommt ihr steckt
sie zum beispiel in etwas styropor oder
in einen kick box ständer hills mine
kickbox steller nicht gefunden das ist
eigentlich einer für diese push up kicks
es geht hier aber nicht die sind zu fest
deswegen habe ich mir einen einfach
gebastelt und zwar mit einem abkühlen
gitter und streik lesern
man kann ich die nämlich hier so
abstellen
jetzt kann ich die dekoration herstellen
dafür rote modell ist schokolade bereits
weiß geknetet und die rolle ich jetzt
ganz dünn aus
jetzt habe ich hier einen kreis aus
stecher und das etwas größer als die
knospe und so sollte es auch sein also
nicht kleiner
jetzt schlechter prognose fünf blätter
aus
und damit die blätter ist etwas
realistischer aussehen mache ich so
etwas dünner das geht es hier zu einem
ball tour und einer schaumstoff platte
und dafür streiche ich jetzt hier am
rand entlang sieht man auch direkt wie
es bisher dünner wird
und jetzt könnt ihr die knospe entweder
noch mal mit schokolade bestreichen oder
zb mit dem fv an kleber und den so ein
bisschen drüber geben also ein paar
punkte jetzt wird das erste blüten platz
drumherum gewickelt und zwar so dass es
oben verschlossen ist
da unten wird dann ein bisschen an
gedrückt da kommt das zweite direkt
darüber an die offene stelle und immer
da wo sie jetzt auf league kommt immer
ein bisschen kleber mit rein
bevor ich es jetzt komplett verschließen
kommen die restlichen blätter mit rein
und es wird jetzt immer überlappend
geklebt also hier ein bisschen kleber
das zweite platz an weiter wickeln damit
der kleber das nächste platz und dann
das letzte blatt
und jetzt ist ganz wichtig dass unten
alles verschlossen wird das heißt die
rosenblätter immer schön am städel
entlang fest drücken
und jetzt bringe ich mit dem modell
werkzeug blätter noch ein bisschen in
form
und so kann ich die rose erstmal zur
seite stellen
hierfür ein kleiner tipp am besten setzt
die zwei ersten blätter wird direkt
gegenüber also dass eine verschlossene
dann gegenüber das andere verschließt
hier auch dann habt ihr nämlich komplett
diesen kegel einmal verschlossen und da
kommen dann die restlichen blüten außen
herum
das habe ich hier grüne heute leer
schokolade bereits dünn ausgerollt und
kann jetzt mit einem ausstecher noch die
kelchblätter ausstechen
jetzt nehme ich jeweils ein kelch platz
und steche mit dem cake pops stick
hinein und dann wird es einfach nur noch
an die rose geklebt nicht ganz flach
sondern immer so ein bisschen locker
lassen
ich werde die rosen jetzt anrichten und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier etwas
rohrzucker in ein gas gefüllt man kann
die rosen jetzt richtig schön
reinstecken wieso kleinen blumenstrauß
und so kam es dann eben auch ganz gut
transportieren und auch verschenken
lässt einfach schleife um das glas herum
und die cake pops sollten auf jeden fall
kühl gelagert werden als im kühlschrank
die kickboxer jetzt fertig und ich finde
sie sind wirklich eine ganz tolle
geschenkidee vor allem kann man sie
wirklich wunderschön verpackt servieren
oder verschenken besser gesagt ich
glaube meine mama wird sich da richtig
toll darüber freuen
eigentlich jetzt steuerlich probieren
sollen wir mal vor der kamera aber
spielen schüchtern deswegen die band
aber ich zeige euch auf jeden fall wie
die rosen cake pops von innen aussehen
und zwar habe ich hier einen schon
angesetzten hoch ist der neue murat
unserem ihrer effekt und die cake pops
kann man auch ganz gut wirklich 345
tages sogar aufheben weil wir sie
einfach mit einer garage gemacht haben
und man eine garage wirklich lange
aufheben kann
samira macht hier die kamera effekte
wirklich schön wie bei der hochzeit ich
das fast oder maximal weiter öffnen und
sagen wie es schmeckt mit einem hart es
ist alles weg und lecker das schmeckt
halt wirklich extrem nach weißer
schokolade wirklich toll vor allem durch
die moderne schokolade und durch die
füllung und bei uns eben auch noch
richtig zitrone also basiert dieses
rezept nach machen wollt geht als
minister of day versteht es noch mal
ganz genau ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr das nach macht und mir ein foto auf
facebook oder instagram sendet also bis
zum nächsten mal
auch tschüss
mit dabei das heißt mein papa trinken
fast alle sehen würde dahinter die omada
der oper dem rad kommt ständig ins
mädels haben
macht das rezept nach und teil teuer
foto auf unserer facebook oder instagram
seite mit dem hashtag gmbh.de